so i just want to tell you just very  quickly 30 seconds i used to play victim  all the time make excuses blame my  privilege for him everything yes and  then i heard you i didn't like you  that sounds about right anybody who  starts with a lot of excuses doesn't  tend to love me so much at first no but  then i kept listening and why i think  mainly because i knew that you was right  i just didn't like to hear it i  understand i'm sorry i kept listening  i've listened to you for five years now  you've completely changed my life and i  wanted to wait outside to meet you  you've changed your life i just had a  little assist it makes me so happy bro